[Applause]
one by one elected delegates were sworn
in to again begin the process of writing
a new constitution for Chile
this time there are only 50 of them far
fewer than the convention that Drew up a
draft Constitution last year the
Chileans ultimately rejected as too
radical
opening the council president Gabriel
boric appealed to delegates to seek
consensus
I hope this constitution will bring our
citizens closer to politics that it will
highlight the importance of dialogue
between people who think differently to
reach Accords for the good of the
country a constitution that will deliver
long-term certainty and stability
Council was dominated by the left this
time the pendulum has swung the other
way with conservatives now dominating
the chamber
in an attempt to avoid the mistakes made
last time Congress appointed a
bipartisan Commission of experts to
write a preliminary draft that had to
include defining Chile as a republic
that guarantees social rights and
equality it is a less ambitious version
than the last one however the right-wing
Republican party has enough votes in
this Council now to veto anything that
it chooses
and that is fueling fears that a new
Constitution that is supposed to finally
replace the one written under Chile's
former military dictatorship will fall
far short of what the country needs
this process has to take charge of the
social demands that led to an important
Uprising in this country that will be
the key challenge for this Council
concern even for moderate conservatives
like Gloria Hut
we have to avoid falling into the same
trap we did last year in which a
majority imposed its will without
listening to the minority that would be
a mistake because we need a constitution
that will be respected by governments
from the left to right and the center
there must be a consensus
side extreme right-wing protesters many
of whom supported the former
dictatorship decried the council as a
betrayal while inside delegates promise
dialogue and cooperation
the question is will it last
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Santiago